et ça va bousiller ta vie 20 30 40 ans
après l'exemple le plus célèbre c'est
marie laforêt donc il subitement se
souvient qu'à trois ans et demi a été
violée et comment tu gères ça après
avoir les individus que ça fait aussi sa
fabrique dans la société
bien sûr mais c'est un crime contre
l'humanité santé publique font dans ce
nom c'est karim moi ce que je trouve
absolument écoeurantes est stupéfiant
au-delà du fait déjà qu'on ait tant de
difficultés à écouter ses enfants au
delà du fait que des instances complices
effectivement en terre les affaires
c'est aussi des complicités des parents
et de la famille quoi et ça s'est jamais
pratiquement condamné c'est à dire que
très souvent lorsqu'il s'agit d'un des
parents l'autre parent est au courant ou
alors une partie de la famille est au
courant on l'a vu avec les abus dans
l'église où on a vu dans ce rapport
aussi qu'effectivement les familles
intérêt ça eh bien moi je pense que
lorsque l'on est parent où on tente ou
même voisin etc on ne dénonce pas ses
crimes on doit être punis sévèrement
c'est là on est très très loin juste on
est très très loin de le faire face que
péniblement on va réussir à punir les
bourreaux péniblement et on en est loin
mais encore mais que va-t-on dire du
voisin qui entend tous les jours des
choses ou qui s'interrogent et qui ne
dit rien de l'enseignant de tout le
monde la famille et du part entière
saissac et scandaleux et maintenant une
petite peine en disant mais la pauvre
elle pouvait pas en parler parce que
sont mario était en prison vous rendez
compte serait détruit la famille mais ça
il faut arrêter sa 4e phase que nous à
voir ceux de voir les filles allemand et
en plus on laisse le part entière avec
l'autorité parentale
déjà le bourreau parfois que l'autorité
parentale
à part entière donc moi je pense que
tout le monde est responsable il ya un
numéro d'urgence que l'on peut appeler
quand on a des doutes sur des
maltraitances sur les enfants quelles
qu'elles soient et quand on le fait pas
on est dans la non assistance en
personne en danger et on est des
complices du quotidien